there's this moment in this incredible
single take hallway fight scene and
Netflix's daredevil that's the best
thing that's happened on my television
in a long time it's this moment where
Matt Murdock the blind lawyer who puts
on a mask and becomes daredevil slumps
into the wall on the floor and he's so
exhausted he can't even stand you hardly
ever see this in fight scenes the
traditional way fight scenes work is
usually a flurry of kinetic punches and
shots between two tireless fighters but
Daredevils doing something different
here the concept for the scene is a
novel at all it's a gauntlet Murdock
needs to get to the end this is
reminiscent of the raid where a police
team gets stuck in a tenement building
and the hallways become a deathtrap or
John woos classic gauntlet in
hard-boiled daredevil captures the same
idea of surprise but it takes it a step
further the camera turns and a doorframe
obscures the scene making us imagine the
action through Murdock's blindness while
they switch out stunt doubles this
one-shot aspect of daredevil is the main
reason it's been compared to old boy a
Korean film released in 2003
it's another film where this man wants
revenge and in one scene he fights
through a hallway of men to do it but
the most similar thing between the two
is how exhaustion plays into both dae-su
the hero of Oldboy and Murdock the hero
of daredevil look like they're out of
the punches get sloppy it's a battle to
get to the door this battered exhaustion
which the single take approach
guaranteed drives home what makes
daredevil powerfully different from
other Marvel efforts violence takes a
toll on everyone involved even when you
win